entre les réponses des âmes et les
réponses des femmes sur certains acteurs
et l'appât l'entrepreneuriat on peut
aussi parler la question de l'ambiance
du retour les difficultés rencontrées
lors du retour les freins en retour et
aussi les choses qui peut provoquer un
départ chez les amériques chez les
femmes on voit des choses
le collectif à désirer un collectif de
jeunes jeunes et moins jeunes
entrepreneurs salariés
les gens qui ont des martiniquais qui
ont envie de lutter contre ce qu'on
appelle la fuite des cerveaux ou alors
le dépeuplement fait de la martinique
donc là ce soir on s'est dit quoi
balancer quelques actions ce soir on
s'est dit on va donner un rendez-vous
physique aux gens on a envoyé
l'invitation a dit venez venez échanger
venez témoigner
venez vous inspirer la première chose
qui fait déjà rentrés ce se rapprocher
de sa famille d'une manière ou d'une
autre
la deuxième chose qui donne envie aux
gens de rentrer c'est s'engager pour le
développement de son territoire
donc ça s'est passé quelque chose qui
pour le coup ma mamma surprise parce que
par rapport aux pronostics on a faim on
n'avait pas anticipé ce lui avais
s'engager pour leur ponton le
développement de son territoire c'est le
deuxième moteur du retour et ensuite
trouver un travail
donc tout ce qui a été dit ce soir je
rentre dans tout ça en même temps j'ai
un profil sub surdiplômés atypique
alors donc je vais faire très court pour
que vous compreniez bien j'ai un diplôme
de notaire
j'ai un diplôme de responsable des
affaires juridiques j'ai un diplôme eux
deux
qu'est ce que je vais encore droite la
construction je sais même plus ce que
j'ai fait manger j'essaye de répondre à
madame en fait ce pardon à la peur en
gros j'avais un petit post pas peur
j'étais en martinique noter leurs grands
bureaux climatisés vos salaires de tout
ce qui va en fait sauf que à un moment
j'étais en quête de sens j'adore mon job
j'adore toujours mon job de notaire mais
il manque un truc
et comme je suis de nature curieuse faut
savoir que moi mais cinq semaines de
vacances
sur les cinq semaines de vacances
annuelles j'en prends trois à quatre
pour faire de la formation
j'arrive s'investir changer de vie la
décision de s'embarquer dans un avion et
de changer de vie complètement
c'est pas facile c'est pas donné à tout
le monde on a tous une histoire de vie
qu'il faut pouvoir break
donc merci à vous tous qui êtes venus ce
soir ce travail est collectif et pas
plus le mien que le faute que celui du
cev que celui des huit nouvelles d'alex
bill haas qui étaient là tout à l'heure
de steve de tous les copains qui sont là
et copines qui sont là autour d'ali
river
c'est notre travail son groupe de
martiniquais qui a eu envie de donner de
son temps et son énergie
quand vous concevez sera prêt je vous
invite à nous rejoindre
puisque martinique ses plus belles pays
[Applaudissements]
justement vous remercier d'avoir
peut-être connu d'accord
d'être venu merci merci à catherine pour
son soutien parce que c'est vrai qu'elle
son discours elle pousse réponse croit
dès qu'on se voie
a toujours ce petit mot pour booster un
petit peu boosté donc vraiment grand
merci à toi à tout ce que tu fais don
pour aller vers et pour moi il est
vraiment top
et c'est vrai que comme le disait déjà
parce que je n'ai pas dit de tout à
l'heure en premier quand tu parlais du
retour mais c'est ça le truc c'est que
déjà s'investit rentrée évidemment sa
famille demain demander fermé de
management au mollet gauche
j'ai appelé mon père on fait la bouffe
etc et c'est un bonheur se dire que tu
es chez toi tu vois ta famille tu vois
tes tantes les tontons donc tout ce que
tu veux et tu bosses tu à faire dans 7
pays donc c'est vrai c'est vraiment
c'est un kiff a en tout cas l'idée c'est
plutôt de c vraiment de s'inspirer de
2,2 de créer un petit mouvement et il y
aura beaucoup d'autres actions si l'on
arrive et y arriver d'ici la fin d'année
l'année prochaine pour agir agir contre
cc c'est ce qu'on appelle vraiment le
développement le dépeuplement de la
martinique ou la fuite des serveurs